- You look beautiful.
- Thank you so much.
I'm so happy to be here.
- Oh my God, I'm super stoked.
- It's my first time on your show.
- Okay, and also, like I watch you so much
in everything you do.
Literally, one of my
favorite jokes I make,
is "Zero Dark Thirty,"
it's when I go dark.
I'm not lying, you're so good.
- You are.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- No, she was literally,
I was referencing her
before the door opened.
I didn't even say your name,
and she was like, "It's coming." (claps)
She was so excited.
- Oh, my gosh.
Well, I told everyone backstage,
I was a little nervous to meet you
'cause I just adore you so.
- Oh, my gosh.
Well, feeling is mutual.
- There we go.
- All right.
- Can we be friends?
- Well, we can be friends.
We're friends. I'm gonna tell everyone.
Okay. Congrats on your Oscar win again.
- Thank you.
- That was incredible.
(audience applauding)
That was so cool.
Do you have like a place you keep awards?
- Well, (chuckles) it's
in a, like an office room
on a bookshelf with-
- Oh, that's where my...
See, people make fun of me.
- [Jessica] Really.
- But I feel like a tool
if I put it out, you know?
Now, one of my friends
is mad at me right now,
'cause you walk in his house,
and they're like right there.
- Is there like a spotlight on?
You open the front door
and it looks like a shrine.
- It is.
Literal it like a piano.
It's amazing, I love it.
But it's so exciting.
You earned it. You did it, I love it.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
But this all kind of started out,
I didn't know this about you.
So, you went to Julliard?
- Yeah.
- But you went on scholarship
that Robin Williams paid for?
- I know.
What an incredible human
being that guy was.
- I didn't know that.
- Yeah.
- Did you meet him?
- I sadly did not.
So, the scholarship was a huge deal.
I'm the first person in my
family to go to college.
It paid for all of my schooling.
It paid for me to be able
to go home for Christmas
and see my family.
All my books, my apartment, everything.
And so, every year I wrote
a letter to thank him,
but I never got to meet him.
And I was in L.A, I had a meeting
with a independent film
director at Fred Siegel
or something in the cafe.
And I told him the story,
and all of a sudden, Robin Williams
walks into the restaurant area.
And I was like, "Oh my gosh."
And he goes, "You have to go say hi."
And it's like, "Okay, okay."
And then I thought, "You know what?
I'm gonna let him enjoy his meal first.
I don't wanna rush over there.
- Oh, that's polite.
- Yeah.
But then in the middle of the meal,
he jumped up and ran out.
So, I jumped up like
I was gonna chase him.
And then I thought, "No,
I don't wanna scare him."
And I didn't go up to him.
And I always regret that because I never
then had the opportunity to meet him.
And I say to people, anytime
someone comes up to me,
I'm always like, "Thank
you for coming up."
Because this happened to me once
where I had an opportunity to meet someone
that I really wanted to talk
to and I didn't take it.
So, now whenever someone comes up to me
I'm so happy to say hi to them.
- Yeah, well and especially,
he probably would've loved that
to see where his money went.
You know that's cool.
- After I tapped-
- You had a reason to go up.
You weren't just like the
rest of us and had no reason,
like we're just fans.
You had a really solid reason.
I'm sorry you didn't get that.
But it's a really good lesson though.
- It is. It's a great lesson.
- For all of us to really
take advantage of the moment.
I just love this, because
you're so classy to me,
and you're this amazing actress.
And you love "Real Housewives."
- I'm obsessed.
Do you not?
- What?
- Doesn't everyone love "Real Housewives?"
(audience applauding)
- I don't. I don't generally watch.
So, what's your favorite
thing about it? Why?
My friends love it.
- I like to find the characters on it.
Like when I did "A Most Violent Year,"
I binged watched "The Real
Housewives of New Jersey."
So, all those hand gestures-
- I love that, that was your...
You know what I should do? "New Jersey."
- It was there. It was there.
And what I'd love so much about the show,
is they take really eccentric people.
Right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then, because by nature
of being on television,
it's all magnified.
So, all these like really
interesting things about them,
are so much bigger.
And I kinda steal it for my characters.
- Oh, my gosh, that's incredible.
What's your favorite one?
There's a lot of them?
- I have so many favorites,
but I think, of course,
"Beverly Hills" might be
the the OG for me.
I love Garcelle.
I'm obsessed with Garcelle, 'cause she,
I mean, we all just
need a friend like her.
She's just so honest all the time.
And I love her. I love her, she
doesn't care about anything.
- All my friends are honest.
I could use a liar.
(audience laughing)
All my friends are really honest.
So, I was like...
I'm just kidding, I love that.
I heard that you like to
mess with people on set.
Like you mess with, was it
James McAvoy that you did?
So, what did you do to him?
- So, this also it takes...
I've worked with James McAvoy.
I've done three films with him,
and he fun-
- You felt comfortable?
- I felt comfortable.
You gotta really plan who to prank.
I just also worked with Michael Shannon.
Probably, not the guy to prank.
(audience laughing)
Can you imagine that?
- Just letting you know.
- So, yeah, we were shooting
"X-Men," and he is Professor X.
And he's in the wheelchair, and
at some point he's on wires,
and at some point he's being lifted up.
And he does the scene and it's good.
And I had planned this with the director,
and the director said, "Okay, final take.
Please do it again."
So, they lift him up and he's acting,
you know, like he's being
lifted by this magic,
or whatever it is.
And all of a sudden, the
"Macarena" starts playing.
(audience laughing)
And the guys that were holding the wires
were having him dance the "Macarena."
It was probably, there's no topping it.
I think it was the best.
- Yeah, that's awesome that
when you have friends like that,
that you know you can prank
like that, and they'll lean in.
- Oh yeah, he leaned in.
In fact at one point,
'cause he was at the top of the stairs,
at one point, he kinda like grabbed me
and lifted me off the ground.
And that's when I was
like, "Oh yeah, no, no.
We gotta stop because
I could now get hurt."
(audience laughing)
So, he was good fun.
- Oh, I love that. That's fun.
I wanna ask you about
something more serious,
because you went to a Ukraine recently,
right?
- [Jessica] Yeah.
- And this, it's really
important to a lot of people.
But why did you feel
like you wanted to go?
- I have a lot of friends
who are Ukrainian.
I was talking to someone
when everything first started to happen.
And I said how sad I was and asked,
said, "Please if there's anything
that I could ever do
to help, let me know."
And then, I was reached out to,
to ask if I would go and visit?
- Yeah.
- And I said, absolutely.
It was a pretty intense thing.
I've never done anything like that before.
I mean, I flew to Warsaw,
and then drove like 4.5
hours to a train station,
and then took a train for
12 hours to get to Kiev.
- Wow.
- Yeah. You know?
And for the most of the
journey without a translator
and without security, I mean,
it was just me and my friend.
And when I got there, I met
so many incredible people.
I went to the children's hospital there.
I mean, my heart's just breaking
with everything that
they're struggling with.
I don't understand, every
time I open the news,
I'm just so sad about the things
that are happening in this world.
You know, the stuff
that's happening in Iran.
It's a constant sense of,
we really need to look out for each other,
and we really need to...
For me, I wanna use my platform to amplify
the voices of those that
are fighting for freedom.
- And you get to tell their stories.
That's what I love about movies too,
it's such a cool vessel
to tell people's stories.
Which, by the way, I didn't
know "The Good Nurse"
was a true story until the very end.
And my sister and I were like, "What?"
(panel laughing)
I didn't know it was a true...
Spoiler alert.
(audience laughing)
But it's a true...
It's already out there.
I just was an idiot and didn't know.
And I was just like, "What?"
So, But it's cool though
that you get to tell people's stories.
I think that's powerful.
- Yeah.
- Able to use your platform like that.
Cause that impacts people.
Art impacts people in a different way.
- It does.
- Than seeing you on the news.
I grew up wanting to know women's stories.
In the history books, I
wasn't really learning
about women's heroism.
And women are superheroes.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so, learning about
all these true stories
of these incredible women,
and especially Amy Loughren,
I love to be able to
use my profession to go,
"Oh, hey you guys,
I know there's all these
other superheroes out there,
but look at this woman right here."
And we could all be like that,
and we could all be inspired by her.
- No, literally it blew my mind
when I found out it was real at the end.
I didn't know.
I literally went into it blind.
I didn't know it's a
plot. I didn't, no idea.
- And you know, a lot of gets
exaggerated in Hollywood.
And I don't wanna give any spoilers,
but the last scene in the
movie really happened.
It wasn't exaggerated.
- I can't believe it.
- It's insane.
Our film really is, the media,
there's a lot of teaching the lesson
of using violence to stop violence.
You always see the them going out there,
chasing the bad guy with the gun.
And there's a shootout, and
then you get the bad guys.
Our story really was like,
well, what happens if this woman
uses compassion and empathy,
and reminds someone
that he's a human being
when other people are
treating him as a monster?
And that compassion is what
stops the cycle of violence.
- And that empathy is the superpower.
- [Jessica] Exactly.
- Yeah, being empathetic
is the superpower.
So many messages there for
all of us to learn, obviously.
But you two are incredible.
I mean, I love you separately.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- It was like a masterclass in acting.
Like even what your character
is going through physically,
while having this whole story happen,
and her family, and being a
single mom, it was just a lot.
I found it in incredible.
- Yeah. So, Amy's a single
mom, the two daughters.
And I mean, this is all true story.
She had suffered from cardiomyopathy,
which means she needed a heart transplant,
and she was working as a night nurse.
Her heart was not allowed
to go above a certain beats per minute.
And all this is happening.
Being a nurse is a very physical job,
people underestimate that.
- Yeah.
- You're constantly carrying
people and turning them,
and you're running and doing compressions.
Compressions are very physical.
And that was actually, that
was the best part for me,
is that when nurses saw the film
they said you got the compressions right.
Because, I mean, we went to
nursing school, Eddie and I,
and I guess the whole thing,
a lot of times in movies,
you see people bend their wrist.
- No.
- You're never supposed to.
Exactly, use your core.
- Which I am so much of, so
that's why it was helpful.
- But also you're-
- Covered in core.
- In you're mind,
the whole time that you're
doing compressions, think,
♪ Ah, ha, ha, ha, stayin'
alive, stayin' alive ♪
- Oh my god. Are you?
- Yes. And that's the
beat of the compressions.
- Oh, my god, I didn't know that.
(audience applauding)
- So, everyone's on-
- My teacher did not teach me that.
- Yeah, but that's the beat.
That's how you're supposed to
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- Look what you just taught
us. The more you know.
So, you and Eddie Redmayne
you said y'all went to nurse school,
but I heard that Eddie
didn't do so great in it.
I heard that he wasn't like super great.
- Here's the thing.
That's what Eddie says.
He is probably the kindest
person I've ever met.
And the most polite, the
British, very polite.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I do have that kind of
American cowboy mentality
where someone shows me
something and I'm like,
"Yeah, let me try it."
So, I would just jump on in,
trying to give a mannequin, and an IV,
and Eddie's like, "Oh, hold on."
And he's really nervous about it.
So, what we came to realize
after our nursing school in our film,
is that neither one of
us would be a good nurse.
I mean, you stick to the professionals,
because I mean, I can look like it,
I can be very confident
while I'm doing it
- You definitely look like it.
- But no, I'm not the
one you want an IV from.
- Yeah. I don't think
that's my calling either.
You're also, I have to mention
this 'cause I'm a musician.
I love this, I'm excited about it.
- That's why I'm nervous
to talk about with you.
- What? I'm so excited.
You're in an upcoming
series about George Jones
and Tammy friggin' Wynette.
(audience applauding)
I'm so excited.
Why are you?
- What?
So, you're singing in it?
- Yeah.
- I'm so excited.
And she has a very specific
tone, so it's like...
I'm so excited.
And first of all, do you only like
playing people named Tammy? (laughs)
- I know, right?
If I had a nickel for every Tammy I play,
I'll have nine cents.
- I'm very excited about this.
Are you so stoked about this?
- I'm stoked. I love it.
Mike Shannon plays George Jones.
We worked with Ron Browning.
He's a vocal coach from
Nashville on the music.
It was very stressful.
One thing, it's probably
the most nervous thing
that makes me, even talking
about, it gives me like hives.
But I drank a lot of bourbon.
(audience applauding)
And I got through it. I got through it.
- And not because you had
a cold or sinus infection?
- Oh, no.
- You're just like.
- But we called it my medicinal tea.
At 10:00 am I was like, "I'd
like a medicinal tea, please."
(audience laughing)
I cannot wait to see the George
Jones-Tammy Wynette thing.
That's so cool.
- We'll get it to you first.
- I cannot wait to see it.
You're gonna be incredibly.
We need to do a break.
I don't want to, but we have to.
And before we go, are you competitive?
You seem competitive.
I'm actually not.
But I can pretend that I'm super-
- You're an actor. Get into it.
- You saw "Zero Dark
Thirty," I'm competitive.
- Exactly. Exactly.
Great, because we have
a game coming up next,
so you have no choice
and you have to play.
"The Good Nurse" is in theaters tomorrow,
and on Netflix, October 26th.
You gotta see this movie.